il semblerait que les etats-unis se
saisisse de la moindre occasion pour
infliger à la russie des avanies en tous
genres la sphère camila vallejo en est
une nouvelle preuve pour rappel la
patineuse russe de 15 ans a été testée
positive un produit dopant en décembre
un résultat communiqué celui février
soit un jour après sa victoire partagée
avec ses compatriotes dans l'épreuve par
équipes aux jeux olympiques de pékin ce
14 février le tribunal arbitral du sport
a autorisé camila vallejo a continué les
jeux olympiques de pékin une décision
qui déçoit le comité olympique américain
les athlètes ont le droit de savoir si
le concours sur un pied d'égalité
malheureusement aujourd'hui ce droit est
bafoué cela semble être un nouveau
chapitre dans l'histoire du mépris
systémique et généralisée de la russie
pour le sport sans dopage
pour certains médias américains
toutefois ce scandale révèle avant tout
les erreurs telles antidopage mondiale
la sphère camila vallejo a est un
réquisitoire contre le système
antidopage pas contre elle l'histoire
avec valiev à démasquer une fois de plus
l' agence mondiale antidopage avec sa
toxicologie de mauvaise qualité ces
persécutions arbitraire et ses spirales
juridique sans fin les obsédés du sang
pur et les rivaux de la russie long au
rang de crimes mondiale et la emma et le
comité international olympique ont
plongé vallier va et tout le monde dans
l'incertitude avec ce processus de
suspension à plusieurs niveaux c'est
bien la championne olympique russe qui
souffrent hall la première de cette
affaire ses jours ont été très compliqué
pour moi et je suis à cours d'émotion je
suis heureuse mais je suis fatigué
émotionnellement donc ce sont des larmes
de bonheur et un peu de chagrin en même
temps je suis bien sûr heureuse d'être
jeux olympiques et de représenter notre
pays un facteur pris en compte par le
tribunal arbitral du sport qui considère
que suspendre l'athlète mineurs avant
d'avoir examiner le fond de la sphère
lui causerait un préjudice je cite
irréparable d'autant plus qu'on peut
s'interroger sur les raisons du laps de
temps écoulé entre le 25 décembre date
du contrôle anti-dopage la patineuse et
le 8 février date où le résultat positif
a été communiqué par un laboratoire
accrédité par l'agencé mondiale
antidopage alors que ce genre de
résultat doit être fourni dans un délai
de 20 jours et quand bien même la jeune
athlète aurait effectivement consommé de
la trimétazidine un médicament utilisé
notamment pour soulager les angines de
poitrine est interdit par la m a depuis
2014 de nombreux médecins russes mais
aussi américains estiment que cette
substance n'a aucun effet sur les
performances sportives au milieu de
cette tourmente camila vallejo peut
malgré tout compter sur le soutien de
son pays y compris celui du kremlin
soutenons notre camila vallejo sans
limite absolument et quoi qu'il arrive
nous appelons tout le monde à la
soutenir et 10 ans à camilla camilla ne
cache pas ton visage tu es russe va
fièrement que ce soit et surtout
participent aux compétitions et triomphe
de tout tes concurrents
même si la russie se réjouit de voir la
jeune prodige continuer les jo il faudra
attendre plusieurs mois avant de
connaître les conséquences de ce test
positif pour camila vallejo et le sport
russe le comité international olympique
a annoncé qu'il attendrait que le fond
de l'affairé soit tranchée pour remettre
leurs médailles aux vainqueurs de
l'épreuve de patinage artistique par
équipes de leur côté les états unis ont
d'ores et déjà brandi la menace d'une
loi adoptée en 2020 qui leur permet de
poursuivre toute personne impliquée dans
une affaire de dopage dans une
compétition internationale il semblerait
bien que la controversée
extraterritorialité de la loi américaine
ne se satisfassent plus de la seule
politique est venu désormais aussi
s'aventurer dans le domaine sportif
au grand dam d'autres nations